the weeks we've done the linear movement
you had some basic concepts which is the
ankle angle the knee vector and the knee
penetration guys remember that okay so
your needs that your knee doesn't go out
of alignment with your foot right and
all things being equal you weighted
mid-foot balance which is it the middle
of your play and we just call it that
right
it's that area about an inch strip
behind the ball of your foot and before
the arch starts you guys hit that it's a
line so when you came in your arch then
you're violating the knee vector right
when you turn your feet out your weight
is too much towards the heels of that
mid foot right and when I pushed my knee
past my toes I violate the principles on
the back foot or in combination when I
let that
that March come off the you now you
don't have your ground connection nor
your structural integrity so you're
probably not using cook you you're
probably using external forces like
bracing angles and strength okay so that
was like a year ago that video now we
have we're gonna go into the tournament
but it doesn't change any of the
principles okay so I still have to have
my knee on the same vector as my foot is
I still can't push out past my toes
right and I still have to try to have
mid foot weight right so if I was going
to do a you Miyoshi forward right I
would shift my weight I can come to the
toes that will give me the positive
angle on that knee so that it can now
push me forward so that I'm not going to
walk and get caught if any energy
stopping me or I'm trying to push a
greater energy it'll send me backwards I
will not be able to project down into
the ground
does everyone remember that lesson yeah
you don't raise your hand will
demonstrate it again okay because not
everyone is walking like that yet so the
byproduct of that process is that
there's no weight on this foot remember
that
so that's what we're going to combine
but in classic kids and young theory I'm
going to now do it for a circle that was
the line I'm gonna do it for a circle
just like in the other one there's
always a little league in and the young
that's gonna be a little longer to hit
so when I wanted to turn right I'm going
to put my foot at the angle that I want
to go at so I'm not doing that is now my
heart shaking so wherever I want to turn
right I can put my foot there but I can
also turn my foot with my hip so this is
going to be obviously home but you're
gonna want to do this not wrong but not
necessarily applicable every time so
we're here and the first drill is bring
your knee to your toes so they share
angle your ankle now has that positive
vector that you could push with that mid
foot push that way okay and all I'm
going to do is connect my foot and my
knee to my hip so that when my hip
rotates all of that rotates you see that
that's the girl here need to toes walk
all that out
what am i turning on I'm turning on that
niche way okay
you can picture like there's something
special under that and you want to bury
it into the ground boom wait on the
mid-foot and you drill down okay let's
try to so just as I'm going to move
forward so that I can push like that
that's the same mid-foot weight that I'm
using to drive into the ground got it
so I'm going to generate that
relationship put me tip right shoulder
elbow angle in this case and I use that
to time so when I go here you see what
happened like mice are Street so I
violate the rule the knee and footage so
roll
yeah okay now the same relationship of
walking we're organizing by an ankle
knee and hip use over here so do the
same drill it's not going to be a
freebie in this so as this hip rotates
around goes around you see how that get
cooking you can't have your hips do this
kind of work so if I lock or organize my
knee and foot to my elbow and shoulder
then as this foot rotates this hip
rotates forward this hip rotates back my
knee and foot will come back without me
stepping then okay so generate the
positive angle drill you see where my so
I don't have to go here and then see
that without nor do I go here and my
foot came across how did he go across
because you broke the organization of
your need to hit do you guys understand
that yeah so I just as you're charting
boom start to go like this
let's burn the head and the foot will go
and you will end up in fund me you will
not end up on the tightrope by keel
which doesn't work it's not Marshall
so hold body boom it'll bring the foot
the gate right
[Music]
all right some beginner mistakes is you
drilling puck you're drilling up because
you actually didn't have this foot D
waited so the only way you're in a D
weight it is to push up then you can
move it on the ground it's not be
weighted because you didn't drive down
into this foot drive down and your
imagery and the sensation of your foot
should be and torquing pressing down the
exact opposite of this okay so here push
down boom take and put more weight on
here not less weight on here okay so
don't spring up second one you're like
two straight you see here your body's
like this okay
so if I push by knee so that I get the
mid foot weight and I sit up you see
that living back here arch pays it
so you're anatomically biomechanically
it's can't do it strategically this is
not a fighting posture okay you want to
engage that rear posterior chain are you
gonna have a camp and you don't want to
get your head knocked off so you're
gonna have a camp you see that you're
not gonna go care like this so if you're
trying to do this on your two straight
you've already set yourself up for
failure all right if I am happen to be
some people have like very frog-like or
points of articulation such that you can
keep that arch down right but it's not
pressurized it's too soft everywhere
right and secondly if you watch my good
here and now when I sit up what's
happening in terms of weight
distribution it's going that way and I
need to do weight that foot you see that
and so you will tend to do it a double
pivot you're going to turn in here maybe
between your feet you see that and the
other one is a single point pivot I'm
turning over my foot you see that so you
have to pay attention to that because
double pivots is when when people hit
you boom they knock you knock you off
the line because you're on a tightrope
so
put as much weight here and don't sit up
of course you might make the opposite
mistake but when you do that what
happened to my knee boy pass my toes so
you violated that rule okay good try I
think so too remember you go back to
this lesson if I don't get that positive
mid foot weight on there right and
basically I'm switching ground path from
one foot to the other
so right now mid foot weights on the
back foot so he's pushing and he's just
grinding that back foot down which is
different from this this is just using
friction and I'm using this bracing
angle so we're here and he's pushing and
he's just grinding that down because
this is not a bracing angle don't let go
as you feel okay okay then that's how
you can do things like this it's just
one brown puppies do you understand that
I know I'm not leaning on him to do this
he's here right and you can see he's
just pushing push he's just doing that
oh no mid-foot mixed with ground into
the ground and you can do different
things with it mid foot into the ground
mid foot into the ground
okay so same thing here when I switch it
when I go to here then that foot is it
and that's what allows that but to walk
you understand that because if I do the
other one and he's pushing and I go like
this then they get me mid-stroke okay so
I'm learning how to make a single foot
the mid foot the ground pal
so the same thing here when I go here I
still have that single foot this was not
doing it okay but what I'm interested in
is rotational integrity so I move my arm
that foot and I'm honesty that my body
[Music]
has rotational integrity meaning I'm not
going to go like this
everything stays connected and organized
the ground path is not necessarily what
I focusing on I'm just using it so I'm
checking quick knee hip elbow shoulder
angle that's already Tegrity that's what
I'm doing
[Music]
don't confuse that with this single
point pivot okay let's try hey if I use
this rotation then weight is still on
that foot then this foot goes back and
then I come back to ankle straight see
that I don't want to come back here I'm
not doing that entertainment
I definitely don't want to be mid
balance so we come back to angle
straight
I started ankle straight I adjust for
the positive vector I drill home this
foot is with me then this foot goes back
don't do wait boom until that foot is
there and you come back to the right
angle of your hand so instead of going
like this where your center of gravity
and your line of gravity between your
feet you see that okay there you go like
this you're double pivoting and the
angle the vector or the line of gravity
is in between no she'll be over this
foot should be over this way then this
foot most straight back and then you
will you return to the new triangle of
your right angle being 90 degrees not
back not forward your knee is going or
your foot is going
so no if you want your knee there what
should you do with your foot turn it
okay and this brings us the linearity or
the young version young element of the
technique here drill block
hey try